hey youtubers is Charlie so now that
arrow is on break it's time to start
talking about season 3 some of the
actors have even been talking about what
is going on with their characters so
what I'm gonna do is a breakdown of what
everyone's been saying and what it might
mean if you're finding me for the first
time I do Marvel and DC videos every
week be sure to subscribe to get
everything this week is just extra
special because the Days of Future past
but feel free to leave me suggestions
for future bonus videos we have several
several weeks before season 3 of arrow
and season one of the flash gets here so
what I'm going to do is just break these
into ten different things in no
particular order I'm just gonna start
with the fun stuff careful for spoilers
from season two if you haven't seen it
yet but number one Merlyn will not be
the main villain but he will be sticking
it to team arrow you can think of him
more as like an antagonist and if we're
lucky an antihero if you're not familiar
with the term it just means a bad guy
that the writers want us to root for and
he's John Barrowman
how could you not root for him Merlyn
and Oliver aren't gonna be enemies like
Slade and Oliver were John Barrowman has
a particular set of skills that just a
little bit different from the new
Bennett II new is just a much bigger
more physically imposing guy you know in
the Schwarzenegger tradition so we're
gonna see a lot more say you know tense
dinner scenes like Oliver had with
brother blood
you know the immovable object meets the
unstoppable force for Chinese takeout
with that in mind I recommend you go
back and watch some of John Barrowman
you know Malcolm Merlyn speeches from
season one particularly starting around
episode 13 for the rest of that season I
don't want to do many any disservice but
John Barrowman is much closer to say
like a Tom Hiddleston low-key villain
than Bane they both just have their
specialties and manooj just happens to
be a little more smashy
also because Merlyn no longer has any
reason to hide his secret identity is
the dark Archer he's gonna be much more
direct whenever he goes up against team
arrow number two Merlyn will be getting
a new dark Archer costume John Barrowman
is a cast regular this season which is a
big upgrade from being a guest actor it
means he gets paid way more money and
gets to be in a ton more episodes he'll
be one of the core characters even more
so than in season 1 so naturally when
someone asked him what he wanted now
that he was a cast regular and so much
more important he said a less
claustrophobic costume like a black
version of Oliver's costume I wonder if
he also meant black
they're pants I can already hear the
jokes whatever his dark Archer costume
ends up being it will be super cool but
plan on some new evil guy threads come
along number three Felicity is going to
get herself into a lot more trouble in
the best possible way when you have a
superpower boyfriend like the flash you
get to take more risks just ask Lois
Lane she used to almost got killed like
every week before DC retcon her
relationship with Superman we're also
gonna learn a lot more about Felicity's
backstory my early theories are that
they're gonna incorporate more of her
comic book backstory more elements from
her in the comic books in just a very
practical way like the way they do with
Laurel you know Laurel did not start out
as the Black Canary even though she's a
character from the comics for example
Felicity Smoak in the comics is the
mother of one half of firestorm if you
don't know who firestorm is he's the
superhero that's made up of two
different people in the firestorm matrix
it's like this timey wimey construct
whereby two people become one and they
can just disassemble and reassemble
matter into whatever they want I don't
see arrow doing something like that
anytime soon it's a little bit crazy but
I do think that they'll include some
Easter eggs from the firestorm or maybe
even the Justice League aspects of the
comics like tying your father and mother
to other known organizations like Argus
or hive good or bad there's no way
Felicity's parents are gonna be just
boring normal people Quentin Lance has
the distinction of being the most normal
dad on the show most average guy and no
one is gonna come swoop in and take that
from him number four Thea is going to
train with Merlyn John Barrowman also
talked about how Thea is gonna learn to
be tougher you know as she said during
the finale
he wasn't explicit on how he was going
to help her become tougher but she will
be physically and mentally training and
possibly sticking it to team arrow and
the people who have been lying to her
for so long that was her main complaint
that was why she left obviously she was
talking about Oliver and Roy but I
mostly expect her to be sticking it to
Roy so look forward to their
relationship going to a really weird
place they still really care about each
other so whenever they fight it'll be
like Batman fighting Talia Roy is way
less cynical than Batman but you know
you get the idea a lot of you also been
asking me about Thea taking on a comic
book persona and suggesting chess Shire
just because she bears a physical
resemblance to her I think it'll be a
little bit
or like laurels arc in season 2 you know
not focusing on comic-book names
specifically just showing her using
weapons with more and more confidence I
think it's gonna take fiha all season to
even get close to a comic book persona
if that's what they're even doing with
her think about how long it took Roy to
get his mask and no one has even called
him by a superhero name yet so he hasn't
even gotten to persona
although the producers have said that
he's the Arsenal version of Roy Harper
just no one on the show has said it to
him out loud yet number five Roy is
going to be Arsenal full-time now that
the distraction formerly known as Thea
queen is out of his life as far as he
knows he'll just do what every typical
dude does and throw himself into his
work so he won't have to think about her
until she starts shooting arrows in his
face because he gets to be Arsenal all
season though I expect them to give him
some more blüdhaven Nightwing stories or
you know stories that existed in the
Nightwing universe arrow does a really
good job of taking comic book stories or
pieces of comic book stories and
repurposing them for the show so there
aren't a lot of direct page-to-page
adaptations but I think Roy will be
doing some very Nightwing like things I
know everyone really wants Robbie Amell
to come on the show and actually be
Nightwing though but number six
there will be no Nightwing or other big
Batman characters
Nightwing is basically like the
character that Roy inhabits right now
he's like Nightwing to Oliver's Batman
but I do think we're gonna see another
superhero from the comics and the main
villain will be someone from the comics
obviously but I don't think we're gonna
be seeing a ton of Batman characters
beyond what we've already seen on the
show Gotham on Fox is basically using
all those people and for another show to
use them too it would just be crazy I'm
not counting the League of Assassins in
that group because arrow already used
them first so arrow kind of has a claim
on them right now
number 7 Laurel will get way closer to
Black Canary I don't want to say she's
gonna become Black Canary outright she
could always become white Canary but
Kate Cassidy said in a recent interview
that she has been upping her workout
regimen and she feels like Sarah in the
finale passed the torch to Laurel
whatever she gave her that jacket so
what I think that means is Laurel is
just gonna take a more proactive
approach to crime-fighting not
necessarily as Black Canary but I do
think she'll take a much more active
role in taking down freak of the week
villains you know with her
as well as being a lawyer I know a lot
of you've also been asking about who's
gonna train Laurel to fight obviously I
think Oliver is the best person for that
job just in the same way he trained Roy
number 8 there will be all kinds of
crossovers with the flash Stephen Amell
already confirmed he was in the pilot
episode as we saw in the flash trailer
but there will be characters bouncing
back and forth between both shows those
are going to take two different forms
the most important kind number one will
be episodes like the pilot and the
two-parter on arrow where they introduce
Barry Allen those involved the lead
characters Stephen Amell and Grant
Gustin going on each other's shows I'm
only expecting that to happen in like
two maybe three episodes including the
pilot it'll probably be like one big
story broken into like two or three
parts like the reason Oliver goes to
Central City will also be the reason
Barry comes to Starling city the other
kind of crossover the second kind will
just be like episode 19 where secondary
characters go on each other shows like
Caitlin snow and Cisco Ramon come to
Starling or like Felicity goes to visit
Barry but Oliver doesn't go with her and
vice versa it's not confirmed how many
episodes of the flash we're gonna get
but I'm expecting a full season pick up
with 23 episodes so I only think maybe
three or four those total will be
crossovers of varying degrees and the
same goes for arrow it's not gonna be
like a physical crossover every week but
do expect the characters to reference
you know flash characters and vice-versa
from flash to arrow number nine a whole
lot more Argus and Suicide Squad Amanda
Waller is a key component of Oliver's
new flashbacks so naturally she has to
become a bigger part of his present-day
story and where there's Amanda Waller
there's Suicide Squad Plus Diggle and
Lyla are having a baby I think that
pregnancy is probably gonna take most of
the season to happen it just seems like
her going into labor during the climax
of the season would be like a good story
beats a hit
Oliver's child on the other hand is a
bit of a wild-card I know a lot of you
think that that was just kind of a
throwaway moment meant to show how Moore
cared about her children that she was a
good person but I do think there's a
good chance because he's growing up in
Central City that he'll be part of you
know future of flash crossovers I'm not
expecting to see him a lot though but
fingers crossed that we get a casting
announcement for a seven-year-old
looking actor on the show I'm expecting
Stephen Amell to get so many questions
about
at comic-con so we'll probably get a
little clarification and number ten the
new Big Bad will be a big departure from
what Slade's character was Stephen Amell
was teasing the new villain by comparing
them to Slade he didn't say male or
female
he said that where Slade had been
omnipresent meaning he'd been everywhere
at the same time this new villain would
be much less so that was literally what
he said I think what he meant was is
that you know you had Slade who existed
at all points in time in the story he
was all up in team arrows faced in the
present and he was a core part of
Oliver's time on the island so in season
two that was really never a moment when
Slade wasn't right next to him
physically or watching him from a
distance so the new villain is probably
going to be someone that Oliver may have
heard about but hasn't met yet in the
present day also someone who isn't quite
as personally tied to him as Slade was
based on that we can eliminate Merlyn
because he's almost close enough to be
Oliver's father and through Thea now
they're related by blood I also think
when Stephen Amell said the villain will
not be omnipresent he also was kind of
speaking metaphorically as in this will
not be like a big mega organization the
villain will still be one person I do
expect them to stick with tradition and
use someone from the comics but the list
of viable threats that fit that bill is
pretty small there's Vandal Savage
Rashaad Ghul dr. light Amanda Waller
that'd be a twist
Chyna white and Maxwell Lord all those
villains have you know fairly
practically looking powers like it
wouldn't require crazy special effects
to show them on screen dr. light for
instance would be a great way for them
to connect arrow and flash in the
finales and even though zoom is the big
bad on flash
technically I think it's possible that
they could put off a showdown between
him and Barry til season two like I
don't expect Rick cos net to leave the
show after season one I think it'll be
more like a Merlyn thing but now it's
your turn let me know who do you think
this villain is gonna be in season three
remember it has to be someone who's
common to both arrow and the flash
universes or at least the Justice League
universe and quick update on my schedule
I'm gonna be traveling over the next
couple of days I'm still gonna do the
Q&A so be sure to subscribe to get that
leave me all your questions and I'll be
doing a Days of Future past video
there's a new trailer for Marvel's big
hero six actually it's a Disney movie
it's like the first animated movie that
he's doing based on Marvel characters
since they bought the company I'll try
and do a trailer video for that tomorrow
- right now click here for my breakdown
- the flash trailer and click here to
get that Q&A video I'll add the
annotation as soon as I post it thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tomorrow
high fives